[Music]
we're here we're going to golf and they
said you need a collared shirt so I said
okay this one for this one hmm
although the last time I did this I
learned something we lower the number
the farther it'll go that's correct
yep yeah so I should get out of my car
yes you should get out yeah I'm looking
forward to getting a nice Coca Cola
gotta do so good like like Tiger Woods
is gonna calm yeah you never know like
people will like have like these
beginner's luck things with her man no
I've no beginner like that this is just
this is this is me just being a pro yeah
yeah look at this great sure I had to
buy nobody told me that you have to wear
golf it's pretty standard actually on
most golf courses pls buy that
[Music]
we just got our warm-up on and now we're
gonna hit the course uh you gonna go
first cuz I'm not really sure which way
to hit it like maybe that is the that's
the hole this is like Grand Theft Auto
it's not like grandpa oh the golf game I
didn't realize when I first did my first
golfing course on GTA that you could
skip the drive and just golf took me
forever to drive from T to T okay good
luck okay line up your shot nice swing
real good point toe point okay here we
go it's my first time cheese you did
much better than I did keep your head
down get under it alright there's a it's
really hard green so like tap yep
you should tap I mean come on do a love
tap in debit it just tap it it oh you're
right it's wrong mother bully oh
man you're getting the distance how
sassy plus you get really upset
[Music]
we're now in a hole - well this is the
signature hole so the beverage cart
woman said speaking of beverages I
finally got that coca-cola where did we
hit it I get it the tree yeah you should
do it again
oh there's not a sponsored coca-cola not
at all
they wanna sponsor me I would not say no
because it's my my favorite drinks yeah
after you hear about oh well I mean if
we're talking so does yeah you shouldn't
use that club no no no what are you
doing the holes right there yes Justine
pop up the holes right there I know
where you were aiming no you don't yell
for your on that you're on the fairway
now
[Music]
found it I'm gonna do it again okay Wow
sorry sorry I get so excited no
etiquette nobody here I need party Dolph
your yeah here you turn you're turning
you're turning up yeah golfing is proper
that's what do we do here Oh
drive-through oh I don't like the stick
[Music]